hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be looking at the ingame King and pawn
in game probably the most common in game
that you'll see many times players will
evaluate in their game to come to this
point and see if a game is won or drawn
and some of your top level games you'll
see players resign far in advance
because they've come to this conclusion
in their head but if you're not a GM
then we want to go ahead and know both
sides is your white how to win and if
you're black how to defend correctly so
that if why it's not playing correctly
that you can force a draw in this
position in this position if it's
White's turn it's actually a winning
game if it's blacks turn it's actually a
drawing game and we're going to go over
that first we're going to go over if
it's White's turn and kind of the key
concepts that he needs to be looking at
now a lot of times white will completely
mess this up people know that they need
to get their King involved to protect
this pawn so they will go ahead and
bring in their King to the d3 square
unfortunately this is now a drawing game
what can happen is black can go ahead
and come down to d5 and this is a key
concept in King upon in game that if the
Kings are two spaces between each other
and it's White's turn it's actually a
drawing game if it's blacks turn white
still has the advantage and can easily
win if played correctly but in this
position since it's White's turn it's a
drawing game white play can continue
King 2c3 the black is just going to mare
he can always move to b3 mayor if he
ever tries to go back he can mayor he
can always try to advance his pawn black
king can just follow the pawn all the
way up the board to the c8 square and if
it's eventually going to be a drawn game
there's nothing the white can do so as
we see early on although it looks like
winning position it should be pretty
easy you need very good tactics so as we
talked about before if the Kings are two
spaces between each other and it's
blacks move excuse me if it's White's
move it's a drawn game so we want there
to be two spaces in it's blacks turn so
our first move is actually going to be
d4 okay we are protecting our pawn but
we're two spaces and it's blacks turn so
blacks going to go ahead and move to c6
obviously black can always play terrible
and move away and just make sure when a
little easier but if you place correctly
as you should if you are black keep in
mind if you are black you should be
studying this as well White's going to
go ahead and move to c4 again we want
two spaces in between and it to be
blacks move for a winning position here
so this position we are aligned with our
pawn where two spaces between now
whichever way the King moves we're going
to do something a little bit different
we're going to go in the opposite
direction okay so let's say that black
moves to b6 we are actually going to
move up and occupy the d5 square
okay now black should go ahead and move
to d6 obviously you can run away but
it'll just make things a little easier
and we're going to go ahead and repeat
the same thing that we did before we're
going to go ahead and move to c5 again
same position just one step farther and
whichever way he moves we're going to do
the same thing so if he moves to d7
we're going to go ahead and occupy the
b6 Square and he can go ahead and come
to
the c8 square and right now we're not as
concerned with the to space rule because
we're going to go ahead and start moving
our pond but that will come into play in
just a minute here we're going to go
ahead and promote our pond here to see
for square and blacks going to go ahead
and move to the b8 square now
technically on the we are two spaces but
again we're still moving our pond so
we're going to go ahead and move our
palm one space and now black moves and
now we're going to do the same thing as
before we're going to go ahead and come
to the c6 square two spaces and now it's
blacks turn and now whichever way he
goes we're going to take the opposite
direction now keep in mind if this is
not played correctly if white tries to
just keep promoting his pawn here black
can easily get a stalemate draw out of
this so keep this in mind if you're
black if white doesn't play correctly
it's a pretty pretty easy draw for black
so black is forced to play either be 8
or d8 doesn't matter both will be the
same result let's say b8 now same theme
as before why it's going to go ahead and
come to the d7 square black can no
longer come to the C file and why it's
going to easily promote his pawn to the
c8 square and make it Queen so as we'll
see here let's say King to b7 pawn to c6
and King cannot come to c7 or C 8 and
the next 2 moves we will have a queen
if you really want to rub it in you can
make a rook but in all cases you're
going to win the game fairly easy we're
going to go and take a look at another
position here and go over just another
key concept and just look at if the pawn
is on the bier G file here but clearly
we looked at the last one install that y
can early on take a winning
advantage and make it into a draw if
he's not careful and we'll see that here
too that goes over another key concept
if Y moves to D to blacken just come to
d6 and it's a drawing game and the
reason is they are four spaces between
each other and it's White's move in the
last example we touched on if there are
two spaces in four is no different only
because any time white wants to come up
to the third rank black can respond and
just Marin come to the fifth rank and
now there are two spaces between so it's
if it's four spaces or two spaces and
it's White's turn black has the
advantage and the same thing if there
are two spaces or four spaces and it's
blacks turn then white has the advantage
to just keep those things in mind if
you're on the offense or the defense so
we're going to go ahead and play as you
should and just give you another example
of how it should look so we're going to
come eetu blacks and go ahead and try to
come to mix with d6 and we're going to
move to f3 again black king can't come
two or four spaces between us but black
is going to try to come into the mix
we're going to go ahead and keep going
as far as we can to the GeForce where
black is going to continue his run to
the f6 Square and just as if it was
blacks move and he went from g6 to f6
we're going to go ahead and take this h5
Square now black is going to go ahead
and try to retreat to the h8 corner
that's his best bet of drawing a a
stalemate or a draw so he's going to
come to the g7 Square and we're going to
just repeat the same process we're going
to come to the g5 Square in whichever
place he goes we're going to go the
opposite so if he comes to the f7 Square
we're just going to drop here to the h6
Square and then black is going to
retreat to the h8 Square and then we're
going to simply bring up our pawn and
promote and win the game so we'll go
ahead and play that out black will go
ahead and just go to the corner and we
will go ahead and bring our pawn and
black can go ahead and continue to bring
this up and just as before we're going
to use the same tactic that we always
have we're going to go ahead and move
here and we're two spaces between and
it's blacks turn to move whichever way
he doesn't go we're going to go so he's
probably going to go to the h8 square
and we're going to go ahead and move our
King to the f7 Square now as king only
has one spot to go so it's going to go
to the h7 square we're going to go ahead
and start promoting our pawn here and
put them in check and he's going to
continue to retreat to the h8 square and
we're going to put him in check and the
only place he has to go is the h7 Square
and we can easily promote to a queen and
from here go on to easily win the game
so I hope this has helped as far as
learning how the King pawn in game works
if you ever find it in your own games
you will now be equipped to win pretty
easy if you do want some some practice
you can actually visit my website where
I've set up a few boards where you can
play in different positions that's the
chess website com
it's also on my youtube page you can
check that out but go there check it out
it's under ingame and king and pond and
you'll see a couple puzzles there but
hope you enjoyed hope you learned a lot
please subscribe to the videos so you
know when new ones are coming out I'm
going to be having a lot of videos
coming out in the near future so hope
you enjoyed and see y'all next video